president Trump raising the stakes of
the standoff over building the border
wall during day 13 of the government
shutdown the president appearing in the
White House press briefing room
surrounded by immigration and law
enforcement officials to say he's not
backing down we need protection in our
country we're gonna make it good the
people of our country want it I have
never had so much support as I have in
the last week over my stance for border
security for border control and for
frankly the wall or the barrier I have
never had anything like it in terms of
calls coming in in terms of people
writing in and tweeting and doing
whatever they have to do I've never had
this much support those same officials
supporting the president's call for more
border security anywhere that you look
where we have built walls they have
worked they have been an absolute
necessity for Border Patrol agents in
securing the border you all gonna ask
yourself this question if I come to your
home do you want me to knock on the
front door or do you want me to climb
through that window these criminal
aliens that have been released from jail
that have been deported will come right
back into the United States however we
had a physical barrier if we had a wall
we will be able to stop that the
stalemate over money for the border wall
set to intensify with Democrats retaking
control of the House Nancy Pelosi is
promising to put pressure on President
Trump and Republicans after reclaiming
the gavel and the speakership just hours
ago Pelosi is also insisting she's not
budging on coughing up money for the
wall are you willing to come up and give
him some of this money for the wall
because apparently that's the sticking
point no nothing does well we're talking
about border security there is no amount
of persuasion he can do to say to us we
want you to do something that is not
effective that cost billions of dollars
all this comes as President Trump
invites congressional leaders back to
the White House tomorrow for more
shutdown talks after a contentious
briefing on border security yesterday
all right so Dan on a day when all the
attention was on and
Pelosi speaker Pelosi big ceremony and
all the nightly newscasts we're going to
leave with that the president comes in
at the end of the day and holds this big
press briefing surrounded by ice agents
and Border Patrol agents and kind of
stole her Thunder a little bit yeah I
thought that was pretty effective did
you it is I think the gops generally had
a problem over the last few decades not
with the message but with messaging I
mean the general idea of low taxes
border security health care freedom and
choice resonates with the majority of
Americans the problem is our messaging
is terrible we never managed to fit
things on a Wheaties box in other words
everything we go to like a methadone
clinic and we're talking about 401ks and
the Laffer curve we've never been able
to say it as easily as Trump this is
about border security that's his message
right now it's clear he has he's a
master at taking over the microphone and
he just did it again and this press
conference I think it was a brilliant
idea come out be snappy get off the
stage and it's a nice response to
speaker Pelosi who's been saying for
almost a year
walls don't work and you have people all
in the border experts who've done this
their whole lives saying everywhere
we've put a barrier they've stopped
illegal immigration and you have other
experts who say we don't need the kind
of wall that Donald Trump's talking
about we need something in the middle of
that so there's a whole list of them you
name one will hurt who is a former CIA
officer congressman from Texas on the
portress these guys because they're down
there is a publican
member of Congress from Texas who says
it's the most costly least effective way
to do border security so there is a
difference I don't believe that at all
okay well it's true
the CIA don't come after me but here
clearly so Donald Trump didn't hold a
press conference he didn't take any
questions so let's just although that
was smart because he takes questions and
then he steps on the message that's true
so two points though on this first
you've had the first Republican senator
today Cory Gardner from Colorado come
out and say the government should reopen
with no wall funding there are senators
on the Republican side who are
vulnerable here who may decide that they
will vote for something the House passes
with no wall funding this is a numbers
game for the president at this point the
other point I would make is that a lot
of people in cable pundit tree including
myself have started talking about this
Daka for wall funding swap my question
is is that even being talked about
inside the negotiating room the
because you don't hear about it from
Trump or the White House you don't hear
about it from Pelosi they're each sort
of in their own corners we're all
talking about a possible compromise here
but are they we know something right
they should be as happening inside the
negotiating room the other day I think
Kirsten Nielsen Department of Homeland
Security Secretary started talking about
the facts and figures on the border and
Chuck and Nancy just cut her off yeah I
thought that was really mean yeah
according to one White House source
truck leaned in and and said you should
interrupt her right and because she was
she was presenting data and and facts
and and she was presenting her case and
then speaker Pelosi comes out and says
the president is allergic to data and
facts so you know clearly this is an
allergy or an affliction that is
spreading to both parties and that's why
we're at an impasse I also don't hear
Nancy Pelosi talking about what the
house can do in terms of immigration
because everyone is hung up on the wall
they're hung up on that four-letter word
and they can't get past it
meanwhile you have a bunch of people who
aren't collecting paychecks others who
who aren't going to work and those were
caught in the middle trying to work in
this country but by some they are being
demonized and my question for Dan is
what if the wall doesn't work because
really the the greatest correlation
between immigration in this country and
when it proliferates is when the economy
is doing really well right now the
economy is doing really well you also
have a lot of illegal immigration but
you generally believe in facts and data
right how do you explain them so much
that there is a significant correlation
between construction of walls and the
decreasing in illegal immigration
traffic and drug trafficking
where there in fact there's a wall in
place how would you explain that any
other way and you know the president
actually just went to Instagram and I
think released a meme the wall is come
home every night guys that's from Game
of Thrones the big picture you've been
watching this is a big picture there's a
big picture you know it I look at it
from the okay as part of the media we
are living in Donald Trump's restaurant
right because around 4:30 he says you
know there's not enough Trump on your
pizza there's not enough Trump in your
soup so he leaves the kitchen
and he comes out and puts more Trump on
your plate which is what he did it for
30 which helps galvanize the media and
then everybody reacts responds but
here's what I want to think about the
real threat to security is a rhetorical
device conflation okay if you think
about the four areas of security border
terror crime and let's say homeowner
home protection guns okay
those are the four areas in each one of
those cases there's the device that is
used to prevent any kind of improvements
in that area is conflation if you look
at immigration conflate illegal
immigration with legal immigration you
can't get a wall with terror
if you conflate religion with extremism
you get Islamophobia that prevents any
movement in the anti-terror world if you
look at policing you conflate law and
order with racism right police brutality
police shootings and then when you look
at the Second Amendment you can flake
gun crime with actually gun ownership so
this is at active use but tactic used by
the left that isn't effective in every
area of security and it's probably most
glaring here because we see that they
both agree on the same thing they both
want border protection but one won't
budge because they're conflating it with
bigotry it's like oh you want a wall you
don't like you don't like brown people
that's what it is you don't like the
people from down so it's like it's like
no actually if you ask if you ask the
Hispanics here they would actually agree
that they believe it's security too but
that conflation is what is destroying
every debate that's my big you say
though that the Democrats and the
Republicans agree they both want border
security I'm not so sure the Democrats
want a hundred percent do we approve we
have proof we have them saying that's my
question and I want someone to pose that
to Chuck Schumer why was that okay 2006
but it's not okay now watch okay
designating forty six billion dollars
for the kind of border security that
everyone is talking about twelve or
thirteen years ago now
but you're not okay with what has
changed well if you're a reporter on
Capitol Hill take that question from
Kennedy and then ask Kron Chuck Schumer
we can get an answer
and then we can find out the truth but
we got a run all right I was just gonna
say what is change from the Senate bill
that passed 100 to nothing under the
last Congress that had no wall fund a